like a soldier just missing his little
Grandma's Boy so buddy didn't bro [ __ ]
it oh that's [ __ ] cool can't buy them
he came by bro manager came through got
him you better show up believe me when
you showed up at the thing he goes my
mouth loves you so he knew my name
well my rabbit's name I just bring him I
have a new rabbit room yeah we're
talking about that little fool in the
car we're here huh what [ __ ] so
what's nipper what's his name slippers
sleepers little white nose some showed
up Oh
China that was cool got a little taste
oh yeah Grandma's Boy Grandma's Boy
right there hello had that forever don't
move yet he did right Bucky Bucky Adams
Bucky Bucky Roberts yeah jeans in that
movie doing papa
Dickie Roberts no yeah booked his day
off
cuz I seen him in there the first time I
seen that for was in homeboys movie do
that fool [ __ ] well so full house I'm
Tempe bro tight fool it was [ __ ] the
first time we ever been in Arizona in
[ __ ] rain like a muhfucka dawg
yeah man we ate sandwiches at the same
place signs in a row I'm a 5 we're at a
place called Ike sandwiches
Ike's place I kept pasta PDS place it
was good [ __ ] bomb ass sandwiches dog
there there are vegan sandwiches
vegetarian [ __ ] regular style but
it's how they make it huh what is it the
[ __ ] sauces a condom is man
condiments a lot of avocado - those
fools have like they were sandwich where
you can add avocado jalapeno poppers and
mozzarella sticks to it yeah they were
eggplant sandwich Britta eggplant we
could add mozzarella sticks and jalapeno
poppers that's it
I know there's Germany Stoppelman I had
that one then there's that other one
that Lydia is something they have won
some to have a vegetarian oh that was
bond the artichokes avocado provolone
and you found out about that place what
like six years ago cuz the rosy one is
in San Francisco
yeah the windows of the Castro district
and at our last you know the Last Comic
Standing I went there with some of the
comedians from the show my Kaplan and
Tommy John again at Royal woods jr. and
there was a big ass line for a big ass
line around around the block and also
they had they had nowhere to sit there
was no chairs there was no there was
nothing nothing give it up a little bag
was their sandwich in your chips and a
soda and that say get the hell out there
so everybody that was eating your
sandwich it was eating it like just
steps of some church or the steps of
somebody's house he's buying somebody's
building so it was getting too busy so
they had to move when they were at that
place you and I went to it was a what do
they call that place when you when you
won and we want to replace it I was a
pop-up I was a pop-up bikes place
because the other play was being
renovated or shut down no they shot him
down so they were well that's when he
opened up the one in a different part of
our San Francisco because we've been to
that one the San Jose one Timmy and
which other ones Salinas Lee said that
every girl gave us and they're all good
for someone had Luton free bread what is
Selena heard a fine bro jacket about to
get to it hidden Selena's dog all fooled
I'll show you a video of your biggest
fan on Facebook bro some fool dog on
Facebook and I don't know his name of
your of your I'm the mad token now doc I
found it
a video of your viewer oh yeah thank you
he don't like you're my husband is dead
joke where that item is trying to find
it here it is start tap dancing dog
Jesus dog and then you know he walked
the wrong with him that's what I'm
talking about
you resurrected my fame blasphemy dog
why you making fun of Jesus Christ for
looking for the way where black people
died though the [ __ ] the
wrestler he from WWE oh my god dude that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious with a good
show huh do they were [ __ ] awesome
dog packed hell yeah I was [ __ ] title
and arrayed yet man it done ring there a
hard heart is helpful so yeah man that
play was messed up huh
dude dude that foot was flying like a
kamikaze dog I mean I the only time I
ever felt that way was on the fight
another fight but I was like
dude what's up with this [ __ ]
and it was just we were up like sideways
dog then one of my friends showed up man
Carlos
Tobar taboo no wrong Carlos wrong taboo
Carlos tow barge its Carlitos throwing
up showed up broken arm talking about on
vacation
mother well for the shoulder broken now
I was driving to phoenix are you running
from the law kids from college so he's
that dude I told you about bro that him
and my brother they had sex with these
two chicks and then they did a
switcheroo and then my no switch a rule
my brother said he thought my brother
wiring a switch he said nah man he want
and he robbed him imagine going home
with these two guys and the other sudden
you're having sex and you get robbed -
damn dude
money don't sleep hell nah dawg don't
get caught slippin you've been robbed
bad chick nah like she took you with you
and then she just didn't give her
nothing or or just blatantly robbed you
I hate when chicks I hardly know or do I
know and it was buy me a drink and I
mean like I'm like buy you a drink
like just telling you [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that even though you like that yeah yeah
we had sex in my mom's college but
that's it man
yeah man
all the women man they don't want to
take off right after though yeah I'll go
pick up their kid they had to be there
before they wake up they got [ __ ] to do
you gotta be there man you don't even
want to hang out and see it just happy
to be sleeping on a bed that not a couch
wow this bed doesn't open up nice these
clothes it's a cool ass bed
this is a Murphy bed that full short I
wasn't there man hey Ben oh hell yeah
deep looking at a real troll baby and
Torres shout out shout out boys really
shout outs already wait a minute no did
we no we did it
shut up - aus - warrior
ass warrior on Twitter
always with his support and never ask
for a shout-out so we're giving him one
today thanks for spreading the word Down
Under
all the way from Sydney Australia shout
out to Nick Chavez from Tempe who came
out to the show this weekend thanks to
all of you for listening and talking
about us on social media keep talking
about it man cause we're moving on up
hell yeah so what else fool not to do
just chillin get prep for this weekend
and [ __ ] going to the deaf song concert
or what I shouldn't - like August I
think but not fat fool to get it ready
huh Agrippa fools getting ready I went
by on Monday though to amoeba they did
an in-store [ __ ] they let everybody
in that was cool they did five songs
man another detail with their
operability of mine or whatever is order
man nah fool dude come on people blow
[ __ ] out of proportion dude everything
you see on the news is like times
[ __ ] 50 dog so although we know what
they don't like me they don't like white
homeless people we went to the Tempe Art
Festival in Tempe and there was a lot of
Art Fair our stuff you know that an old
man art there the old man or blow that
are you by Jazz Fest doors you know that
old man art whittling wood art Winona
wood hard and crafts crafts bro and then
I paintings of beaches come on man oh
it's like these art festivals they never
have like um moko art I like a guy who's
you're gonna cuff an up-and-coming
artist like a troll or uh hell no it's
coming up neither we have these art guys
what does he do
oh he raised ashtrays out of tree bark
jewelry for a lot of jewelry yeah my so
this homeless guy took that I could just
set up with his banjo
it's all oh hell no they kicked his ass
out here Flaco or healthy flat ball
there we'll kick it a couple of people
out of those the ones who were in the
Starbucks
that shows hilarious dude well you don't
want to see that [ __ ] first of all man
we saw the security guard walking with a
dirty - Wow
Red Bull and everyone either made rebels
that BigDog me look at our boy red hell
yeah
there's a funny thing about security
guards man night there was a security
guard messing with a homeless guy in a
banjo telling him to pack up his [ __ ]
and leave and we saw another home
another security guard walking with his
lunch and he didn't even look at other
security guards who helped him he said
[ __ ] I clocked out how about that black
security guard that they sent in to
Starbucks to get those other dudes out
and that brother was looking like man I
don't want to do this man arraigned like
crazy oh there yeah dude I never been to
when it rains you been doin the rain
never dude is dude I've never been there
with weather not hot I've always been
boiling hot dude there was those trippy
dude it was like so remember got all
cold and the first night it rained on us
remember when we're leaving the club
yeah man it was a good show man it was
packed people there people had an
organized line getting photos ready to
merge sorry about that
go to the website puts the website get
your merged people we are we are all my
god that fool showed up well time to
show up and again I totally get one
guess but last time I did he gonna show
up and hang out with brown shoutout yeah
Whoopie oh there no I don't know when
people hang out hang out and just like
I'm doing my said that there's doing
like in a backstage greenroom all right
watch my step go there you know hang on
the comedian bro don't watch my set
don't pick up ideas I have nothing to
teach cuz exponent on the road you know
you don't talking no more they start
doing like two bits or five bits it
sounds similar well you know kind of
they made my father dress up like like a
little girl tool you know the parallel
thinkers out there
great minds think alike they do man so
with a bow job problem is well put in
day well you didn't miss much they lost
they lost I got invited by Jose Huizar
hell yeah couldn't go bowling in my
blood works take care
should have Lisa yeah bro getting fatter
brothers didn't weigh what's going on
what's happened in the relationship
right now right now no you just took it
off no just hanging out you know going
out to the movies eating Marisol
Deadpool don't they put bad I was tight
people talk [ __ ] I thought it was
awesome
I totally good too I left other electro
I don't know about Superman or Batman I
haven't seen that yet no I heard about
it though everybody crying crying that I
saw the cry that was good
both they were sad uh all that [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] it did follow the book or the
comic book and I'll actually for people
who don't watch coming boom and I
gritted more ever seen in my life I give
10 stars people man they never follow
the book by it's Hollywood they gotta
break the story interesting I wouldn't
do a Bible movies Man 3 follow the Bible
Jesus got way more time than that
I heard Thor's went through his eyeballs
well the pastor's say one time when he
was like preaching he said the thorns
when they put the crown on him that they
shoved it down his head and all those
little thorns went inside Jesus head and
some of the thorns went through his arm
high balls and he was walking around was
blood coming out to die for our sins
wrong damn who was telling the story
like he was there huh I remember when I
was like when a Christian and Bible
studies in that place to be douchebags
they were still douchebag Christians bro
walking up to me but can you walk and
carry the cross oh my god can you
brother man I'm just trying to live dog
are you trying to do huh but it's new
you get home huh you put your Bible way
and pick up that porno don't you gonna
carry that cross brother I don't even
got a porno man I got it on my phone
what so fool man you're killing me bro
well what happened I don't know what's
up Tommy Brue April 15th this Friday the
day before the passo show Pasadena
Bassel oh yeah oh yeah oh sure this week
this Friday
yeah time fly man I know huh oh yeah so
you'd be my birthday boy three budget
letting you know I like paints ya mess
week we got this dumb
there's a rabbit cuz wheelchair we're
trying to drop a rabbit a man not a
drama to adopting a rabbit so when I go
to your house everywhere every once in a
while shake up on a rabbit to make sure
you have a nice home they care more
about you rabbit and they do adopting a
son or human being but he's serious yeah
they had to go in and check in that time
the habitat for the rabbits doing good
and you treating the rabbit right and no
one in the room you know yeah it's a
great habitat he's not outside don't
scare him see you don't know when you
yelled at that imagine that do it they
don't even do that for people oh my god
doctor baby we're gonna come in and
check in make sure that this baby's
being treated right and fair right
and nobody's cursing and yelling do you
got to pay for that fool no it's free
vaccinations a [ __ ] about a rabbit that
don't know what yeah we went to be but
it from the person they didn't want the
rabbit no more because there's just no
what the rabbit no more so nobody has
itself a rabbit broke at laps little
rabbit yeah little dwarf right bro
as soon as we open that gate that foo
took off took our run and said what's up
doc it's all I just searching around and
she's our general that's tight
I was checking my I'm checking to see
how many people I see I'm putting a cue
rabbit words yup I'm at 1895 likes nose
is making me laugh did have no button no
bro got to cross a little cool here J
Robert Lhasa so what's our food degree
right yeah yeah yeah how do you talk to
the other person I thought you all you
have with a bachelor's in education or
something no
as a bachelors I mean it's a completed
degree I have one year at Law School
that's a Bachelor than what I'm history
what did you uh what did your arm focus
on civil rights movement civil rights
movement so to teach oh just to go into
the lawyer
uh no just just [ __ ] to have a like a
concentration on like this is a thesis
of a paper due at the end it was nothing
[ __ ] serious dude and that's it but I
don't have a teacher's credential
nothing like that I thought you know the
let me substitute but I mean I didn't
have a teacher credential or desperate
huh well yes opposed to the desperate
now but you know whatever you know other
desperate for right now the one teachers
to go to Hawaii to teach over there and
they were good but see what they're
doing is that because a lot of teachers
were required because the pay is so bad
and so expensive to live there
can't afford a hell no so every once in
a while that I attract people you know
hey come teach in Hawaii
you're by paradise a little ah but once
you get there man you kind of mean
unfortunately up there it'll be like
[ __ ] one of those fools in [ __ ]
Tempe dogs you'll be a homeless
Portuguese Australian guy cuz in why is
it expensive to live there because they
ship everything in there [ __ ] no matter
what I don't know man if it's so
expensive why the Hawaiians to live in
there
you haven't needed to have a mean
teacher shortage over there right now
yeah man produce expensive milkman huh
nobody milks cows over there then what
Keith said we want to do by man a corona
or $20 yeah dude that was trippy dude
and gold is cheap right a little trip
him and I feel broke a home was going
there for cheese matting our guest he
went to he bought gold but then in
auditory told me that when you buy gold
here United States didn't give you the
gold
what's the point my what a certificate
yeah I don't know how that [ __ ] works do
but uh [ __ ] shits my silver I want
the silver phone babe I pull out money
know when you're invest in oil it'll
give you the oil huh it's stashed
somewhere
I thought trucks shoulder broad I
thought a truck showed up
put in my will if your eggs on and [ __ ]
you have the wells but nah it's all pay
perfil so your ex on you you [ __ ] by
all of those tell you the oil that huh
well I'm sure they have their stashes
and the reserves and the distributor set
their water and everything water is
expensive it cost the same amount of as
beer in Dubai yeah out of water I must
say by Dubai I wanted to rag come from
Dubai probably huh anywhere hats look
spilled oh he said also that out do you
he said in Dubai during the day
everybody shuts down their electricity
in their home and they all go hang out
at the mall because the AC stays all day
Oh cuz it's so hot there yeah please
[ __ ] up a mall dog if you're
not here to shop get the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah we're the Bundys 120 degrees 130
you think he's gonna get that hot over
here to dong hell no but I been to Palm
Spring when it's been a hardened oh it
was a long time ago problem I cassette
dick melted on the dashboard not even
looking forward to something right now
yeah man also also man will forget
April 20 we're gonna have that assured
the Icehouse
yeah 4:20 should we announce the
comedian's we're gonna have scruncho
there hell yeah Adam and Melilla Camacho
Melanie Jim Papa Tyra Vera possibly
Jodie aboard a sure if you like to fly
up but we have Joe Diaz we're tourists
yeah yeah man also people please
subscribe to the podcast and also go to
the are things comedy web page where
they have all different types of
podcasts they have been there a than the
Dell razors what else
punch-drunk love punch-drunk sports also
somewhere I guess have podcast on a
podcast ours always means right
but Bobby Lee Tiger batty bro there's a
new number one on the podcast on iTunes
who's that black chicks but he's on
there bro was so full podcast with
Rodrigo Torres
yeah yeah man check this out man we're
gonna be in a Paso show up man
say hello to us shake our hands were
very approachable and also if you have
friends that pass out on a drunk open up
their phones go to iTunes and subscribe
our podcast on their phone for them so
yeah other than that we're gonna be
disappearing soon shut up to the little
rabbit oh also new episode of our
another Castle Rock coming up in next
week follow this Sunday check it out